RETIREMENT THEY WILL PLAY
TOGETHER ON THE SAME ICE IN THE
NHL FOR THE LAST
HERE COMES PALLOTTA THE SHOT
BY TAL WAS 26 HE'S GOT 22 GOAL
PERIOD THAT HAS BEEN CONTROLLED
LARGELY BY THE LIGHTNING  THE O
SHATTENKIRK.
PAST INTO THE AS THAT,
ONLY A ONE GOAL MARGIN NOW. FRO
MAROON , BACKHANDERD AGAIN,
ONE MORE TIME.
THAT WILL DO IT.FLECTION HERE I
THAT IS WHAT FOOLED
VASILEVSKI
VASILEVSKIY GOT THE PAD DOWN ON
WATCH TROYB TERRY NUMBER 19 IN
FRONT OF THE NECK, WATCH HOW
ALEX KILLORN, OFF THE GLOVE OF
STORLARZ AND OVER 3.
>> Brian: KILL LAUREN WITH A
GREAT SHOT THIS WILL BE REALLY
INITIAL LOOK.
I THOUGHT THEY
PAST HEDMAN.
>> Brian: ANAHEIM FEET ACROSS.
ENDS UP WITH KUCHEROV
>> Brian: HE HAS GONE AFTER THE
SHOT
LOST.
JUST DOWN THE FINAL THEY LOST
TO THE STANLEY CUP LAYOFFS.THE
HERE'S DRYSDALE, HIS SHOT, DID
NOT MISS BY MUCH.NG IT.